[Applause]
Beverly has gone to the bench Westbrook
Ops it inside and Davis has nine
nimhar
inside Jackson fumbled it yeah he
mishandled it otherwise he'd have had a
chance to run on the other side Brian's
running
[Applause]
Middleton
gets to the middle and
declaw
it's an obstacle
you know you try to portray it as
opportunities which you have to as a
coach
one more than the Lakers have Westbrook
searching
[Music]
gorgeous pass from Russell Westbrook
there's Westbrook time the attack gets
inside kicks it out Gabriel for the slam
Russell Westbrook a beautiful setup next
two of five from behind the art Clippers
four for seven
[Music]
both teams averaged 12 makes a game it's
the All-Star so he's been feasting
behind the ark Grimes doing a good job
but a good screen by zubach they free
him up Barrett bottled up you know Mars
good slight ahead Atlanta running the
court with the Bandit off the feed from
Jackson and the Knicks called timeout
and the Clippers in transition there's
the
it's Poulter within four
stars
behind the back
it's offensive one the ball was short
there's yours getting a second
opportunity and he's fouled
slick pass you see the whack
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
it's good and he will head to the line
it's the worst Defender folks they have
all of these
stats now
third opportunity for the Clippers
here's George Morris from three it's
good normally the average that in a
whole game they've got that now at the
half and only 20 attempts
back door is wide open
man puts it in and is foul Leonard has
been the featured player
baroness has little success continued
now
all right Leonard knocks it down no Chef
Curry tonight left a doctor injury Ben
Simmons sore left knee expected to play
tomorrow Terence Mann cans it from Long
Range just behind the Denver Nuggets in
three-point percentage Leonard comes to
the ball switch out front he takes it at
Sumner the floater is good and a foul
watch him just moving on the floor and
the interesting thing like you watch a
play like that his eyes he's looking
away
No Deal give it up Claxton back out for
O'Neill
talk he gets popped up in the air
Leonard to George Who lays it in
cam Thomas getting so much attention
you're gonna find those openings with
teammates only two turnovers for La oh
zoobots on a rack attack Clippers are
cooking on the offensive side nice
Bounce by George
31.
letter turns the corner
and he lays it in plus the foul Clippers
with a chance to regain the lead
Clippers with a chance to go back in
front three minutes to play in the third
George the cross on Smith takes it in
quick screws for two
Leonard gets into it quickly spin move
Leonard against Thomas
makes himself available and he punches
it down
rims out rebounded by Leonard that would
have cut it to two instead it's Jackson
with a hammer Jam details of this game
you see the turnover
Camp Thomas going up for the three-point
shot can't get it to go
the quick get ahead there by Kawhi
Leonard no one's back
it and you mentioned the turnover LeBron
it's one out of two from the line he's
32-08 keep an eye on the the scoring
tracker top right he's made of Threes
made a free throw
[Applause]
[Music]
Westbrook working with James nice feed
LeBron James
got hit in the face that's what he does
and he stretches out the defense
Thomas Bryant worried about gildges
Alexander Russell Westbrook feeling it
Kendricks Williams leaning on LeBron
Westbrook and LeBron now pull it past oh
what a find and brown lays it in the
room swells a little bit turnover
Westbrook out in front team's running
with him Westbrook Powers it down
[Applause]
25 for gilges Alexander
Brown will lay it in good ball movement
nine-point game Lakers Trail
and here's James
[Applause]
[Music]
inside Davis on the lob from Westbrook
back to back and that is Westbrook with
the rebound Westbrook's on the drive
head of steam lays it in Westbrook
drives West
finishes
still a two possession game
right now Mavericks up by a dozen Kawhi
Leonard drives on Powell little head
fake kicks it out Terence man wide open
look three-pointers good
he's not the only one playing well
George trying to get going steps back
knocks down the three Georgetown double
figures and Jason quickly calls timeout
Leonard tries a three
[Applause]
coming alive two points in the first
half he's got seven already here in the
third exploded here in the third quarter
Mark oh absolutely got it going
George difficult shot
how many times you say that through the
course of his career tough shot and it
goes good ball denial there Bullock gets
it back
Irving Baseline left-handed slotted Away
by Leonard picked up by Morris what a
decision by Jason Kidd going with Pinson
great decision off the double team
finding huddle George answers right back
with 23.4 remaining it's back to five
again Clippers pulled to within five and
now a leather larceny George the runway
is clear and he takes it in
brings it Allen to 40 three-point
shooter Clippers Now find themselves
down by 12. same spot they were in the
first quarter
Covington retaliates with a three of his
own
Allison instant offense for La shot
clock down to four Leonard didn't catch
it crisfully
now he's got a hoist it
and chance
[Applause]
away and it just made Draymond Green
laugh talk a lot of trash but I mean how
about this shot under duress shot clock
running down and just a few words
between Kauai and Draymond 90 to 89.
Leonard with kaminga the drive the dish
[Applause]
the corner
what an efficient evening to mentioned
it 12 or 17 from the field but where the
Clippers up by 12. gets the handoff from
Leonard ball movement leads to natal
three
another Bullseye from Norman Powell
Paul unable to get it to broke around
the box so they reset out to a kogi
pass inside they turn it over zubas with
a rip
ahead of the field is Mann lines it up
please see Josh a coach right there and
he bouncing two bytes able to get the
ball out into the in transition here's
the confidence you open square up your
feet
[Music]
how quickly can the Suns put it all
together and what they hope will be a
deep run through the postseason's letter
beautiful drop off to man
I just shoot him okay once unseld over
the top now he Kevin Love and then Kawhi
attracting the defense and making the
right Play Because days after Jimmy he
makes one of the splashiest moves in
recent NBA history wasting no time to
put his imprint on this new franchise
Leonard pushing for the Clippers
there comes Leonard turns the quarter go
in glass and he's headed to the
free-throw line
good opportunities throughout the course
of the game you just have to be patient
the last two possessions outside of
Terrence has been able to score this one
was a little miscommunication by Phoenix
whether to switch or not when you don't
do that as we approach the final two
minutes here at Phoenix
Leonard maintains his feet puts it down
fifth was nasty
just trying to run that clock final 60
seconds shot clock down to two
matchup between Paul and George Leonard
flicks it up and in and he's headed to
the free-throw line that Leonard just
happens to be in the right place at the
right time as the ball just trickles
right to him picks it up throws it up
and it's amazing man just go take it for
granted uh when I retire uh if this is
going to be amazing to watch you know
it's already four stars four times but
it's I've been blast man
Pascal siacom Drew holiday getting their
first run here George once again there's
team LeBron opens up scoring and Paul
George with a block up ahead Kyrie
leaves it between the legs for PG
rewarding the defense
Mitchell's got 22. potato keeps adding
on Tatum's got 21.